[Música]
economía nuevamente en directo américa
de france 24 luis méndez su visión para
iniciar hablando de cuba porque las
autoridades de ese país anunciaron que
hoy comenzará la venta de dólares y
otras divisas en esa nación así es raúl
es algo que no ocurría desde el año 2004
cuando
particularmente en el caso de los dos
reses éstos fueron sustituidos por el
peso cubano convertible de acuerdo con
el ministro de economía y planificación
la medida es considerada como un salto
considerable aunque restringido y
gradual en la compleja puesta en marcha
de un auténtico mercado cambiaron el
país el tipo de cambio será de 120 pesos
por dólar un tipo similar al del mercado
informal y al de la compra por parte del
estado de las divisas la operación
tendrá un margen comercial de entre el 3
y el 6 por ciento desde principios de
agosto el estado cubano está comprando
divisas internacionales a un cambio de
120 a 1 hasta entonces el tipo oficial
era de 24 pesos cubanos por la moneda
estadounidense un tipo que se seguirá
manteniendo para empresas y organismos
estatales para el representante del
gobierno en la intención de las
autoridades estaban en la construcción
de un sistema cambiario y retomar su
control las operaciones de venta serán
sólo en 37 casas de cambio oficiales en
efectivo y en primer momento
exclusivamente para personas naturales
el tope inicial por cada ciudadano será
de 100 dólares estadounidenses o la
cantidad equivalente a otra divisa
internacional pero veamos que dijeron
las autoridades respecto a esta medida
eso significa que realmente este tipo de
cambio nuevo estimula las personas para
la venta para la al sistema financiero
de eso les vamos a hablar de malasia
porque fue ratificada la sentencia un
tribunal federal de ese país contra un
ex primer ministro por casos de
corrupción así es raúl se trata de najib
razak quien deberá cumplir una condena
de 12 años de prisión y además pagar una
multa de alrededor de 46 millones de
dólares por cargos relacionados con un
escándalo de corrupción multimillonario
en el fondo de sociedad anónima estatal
desarrollo de malasia también conocida
como one en beat beat lo primero que
debemos explicar es que este fue un
fondo soberano creado en 2009 y en la
que participó yo yo un destacado
financiero malasio esto sirvió para
promover el desarrollo económico en el
jeep como primer ministro de 2009 a 2018
cofundó este fondo y presidió su junta
asesora hasta 2016
el fondo recaudó miles de millones de
dólares en bonos para su uso en
proyectos de inversión y empresas
conjuntas entre 2009 y 2013 pero se
investiga el desvío de 4500 millones de
dólares por parte de las autoridades de
unos 10 países entre ellos eeuu no
obstante el gobierno de malasia señala
que la pérdida de recursos podría rondar
los 7 mil 800 millones de dólares si
bien allí no está siendo investigado
como el principal responsable su
culpabilidad para las autoridades de
malasia está relacionada por ser el
primer funcionario de ese país y sobre
quien pesan cargos de abuso de poder el
lavado de dinero y abuso de confianza
criminal el departamento de justicia de
eeuu dijo que se desviaron unos 4500
millones de dólares a cuentas bancarias
extraterritoriales y empresas ficticias
muchas de ellas vinculadas los fondos
desviados se usaron para comprar activos
bienes para löw y sus asociados y
también para financiar la película de
hollywood el lobo según las autoridades
estadounidense lou es un fugitivo y ha
sido acusado en malasia y estados unidos
por su papel central en el caso él niega
haber actuado mal pero se desconoce su
paradero en malasia ha indicado que está
en china pero beijing lo ha negado nayef
recibirle que al 20 más de mil millones
de dólares rastreables de este fondo las
demandas aseguran que recibió
681 millones de dólares poco antes de
las elecciones del año 2013 en malasia
nadie me ha dicho que él y otros
funcionarios lo engañaron para que
creyera que los fondos depositados en
sus cuentas fueron dominados donados por
la familia saudita y al menos hay países
incluidos singapur y suiza ya han
iniciado investigaciones criminales y de
mala gestión financiera alrededor de
este caso
louis y recientes datos revelan el
deterioro de las principales economías
europeas y es que hoy se dieron a
conocer los datos del psm iv o también
conocido como índices compuestos
gerentes de compras que reflejan el
empeoramiento de las perspectivas y la
menor profesión al consumo de los
hogares como consecuencia de la
incertidumbre y de las presiones
inflacionistas en alemania el pm y
compuesto se situó en agosto en
47,6 puntos una reducción si se compara
con el pm de julio que se sitúen
48,1 el dato de agosto supone la peor
lectura en 26 meses en tanto en francia-
este indicador bajó hasta los 49 ocho
enteros frente a los 51 7 del mes
anterior siendo ésta la peor lectura en
año y medio incluyendo una reducción del
pm y de servicios de 51 a 51 puntos
desde los 53,2 de julio pasado pero esta
situación en las principales economías
de el continente y de la zona de euro
también afectaron a esa región el pmt la
zona euro mostró una caída significativa
de 49 a 49 dos puntos desde los 49
puntos 9 que registró en el mes de julio
al tiempo que en reino unido se situó en
50,9 desde el 52,2 y en china se toman
medidas la sequía que impide la
producción de energía hidroeléctrica
louis así es en este paso se han abierto
las reservas de carbón a nivel nacional
que podrían suministrar 6 millones de
toneladas al año esta situación brindará
de acuerdo con las autoridades chinas un
alivio a la situación de escasez de
carbón aunque un efecto general podría
ser limitado según los expertos en la
industria la continua escasez de energía
obligó a sichuan a frenar el uso
industrial de energía durante más de una
semana el proyecto puede almacenarse en
cientos mil toneladas de carbón en modo
estático y su capacidad de servicio
puede alcanzar los 6 millones de
toneladas al año pero para paliar esta
situación de la falta de energía unas 67
platas de energía térmica fueron
activadas en pleno funcionamiento a
partir del lunes con 12 75 millones de
kilovatios horas de capacidad generada
esto representa el 25 por ciento de la
carga diaria de la red local para
abordar la escasez de electricidad
producto de la sequía cifra el día louis
tiene que ver en este caso con las 700
19.549 todo en el área que ya han
partido de ucrania todo esto en el marco
acordado por la onu también por turquía
y otros países para abastecer de
alimentos a otras regiones
719.000 de las 25 millones de toneladas
aproximadamente estamos muy lejos de
cumplir esa meta aportada por la onu
pero bueno es haciendo el trabajo así se
alentó graciasluis como siempre por toda
la información pasamos a salvar el
maleza para hablar de deportes